you might run a thousand dollars against
it and get no sales and you'll be like
[__] Gary but meanwhile what I know
is that you did get sales you can't
attribute it to it so now people feel
fond towards you three weeks later they
decide to buy it they just go to the
website because they know who you are
but you can't point to the ad and you're
like the ad didn't work Gary thanks for
having us you've been a huge inspiration
to how we built the uh We've listened to
a tinier 4D so it's an honor to be here
humbled
um I'd love to give you just a bit of a
plans you can have more contacts but we
launched last year I think the first
year was us really figuring out do we
have product Market fit to resonate
we've hit that we're at Mid six figure
business right now we're profitable
we're reinvesting every dollar in so
we're barely profitable for customer
acquisition no we have not done any paid
marketing no people Word of Mouth yeah
so that's kind of how we built the
business and kids on the share model
makes sense yeah we both heard uh one of
your podcasts and next they decided
we're doubling down on content so we're
doing about three importances of context
of her social platform we have a
newsletter and her
three or four per platform per week day
per day so how many what total per day
oh um
12 to love I love you yeah so pumped
with you yeah and it's working oh it's
been wonderful did everybody hear that
yeah three times a week
go ahead
there we go my man
progress we're doing a little bit of
influencer marketing in the beginning
and then we decided to double down our
own content yes working way better yes
so it's been fun um you know how like
you know like I always tell people in
this one they're always like Gary why is
that I'm like you know how you love we
all love children
like children we universally all agree
like we love this seven-year-old we love
our children more yeah an influencer can
only love your product so much compared
to you
yeah so
newsletter a bachelor podcast
we're probably YouTube and we're trying
to decide all of that right now
um you want to talk about that for half
a sec because it's super important I
think you'll do well yeah we started to
record content uh we're trying to decide
here we're in we're interviewing a lot
of experts but we also want to do our
own original content so we're we started
recording but we haven't figured it out
when you say your own original cup just
you guys on the show yeah so I would do
both in one show
let me tell you how to figure it out
back to and versus or think in segments
I think the show should start with five
to seven minutes of you guys think about
oh Regis and Kelly like they like banter
in the morning like yes guess close the
show
so I think the way you should do it is
do six seven eight minutes of you guys
30 minutes with the guest six seven
minutes of you guys to close out maybe
that one has like a little segment or a
little game or hot take or you do
something with each other or like for
name Association or whatever
and then you're done
and then you have the post-production
for all of it
segments
and the way we're thinking about it so
YouTube for sure and I have a
personal just passion of mine that gives
me energy I love that thank you and we
had some health interviews and we saw it
really works we would now want to Double
Down on YouTube I guess for us like I
don't know if I'm being too conservative
with our marketing dollars we have not
spent anything like what do you think
how do you think we should probably
can't get more conservative than zero
marketing I mean doubling down on
YouTube like that makes sense when you
guys have tell me a good War story of a
piece of organic content that went viral
go
but one on Instagram it was like over a
million it was this like cocktail
mocktail that we did you should you
should take that video and run ads
against that against Target audiences
because the algorithm aka the human
beings everyone's like Mark Zuckerberg
China it's [__] humans responding to
[__] these platforms are very simple
they just want people to stay on it for
as long as possible so they can run ads
so they're not like like zucks isn't
pushing propaganda of like you loving VR
they're just [__] math
and so so for you that mocktail should
be turned into an ad even if it's not
like because we do a lot of education so
even if it's not our specific product
it's a healthy hormone-friendly correct
it's giving people awareness to your
brand it might not be sales oriented
like you might run a thousand dollars
against it and get no sales and you'll
be like [__] Gary but meanwhile what
I know is that you did get sales you
can't attribute it to it so now people
feel fond towards you three weeks later
they decide to buy it they just go to
the website because they know who you
are but you can't point to the ad and
you're like the ad didn't work well the
ads definitely going to work because it
already went viral people are interested
I'm incredibly bullish on everybody here
running ads after it succeeded on
organic that's something that we haven't
lived in for a long time because it's
not how the platforms worked
so we have it way better than we did the
last 10 years we have to guess and run
money or run micro money see if it
worked and then poured fluid on it now
the algorithm does a better indicator if
it's going to work than even our micro
ad Spence
so like to me if you're going to test
some stuff test it on the things that go
viral on your 12 a day
yes at some point
the holy grail for DTC businesses is to
find scalable math that works in CAC and
LTV the problem is most of them aren't
actually working profitably they're
using VC money to subsidize their
underwater cack and LTV and then there's
eventually a funny game of chicken of
can you sell it before your math Runs
Out which is a [__] challenging game
and one that I don't like to play
because it's like a fake business
yeah
see how the bee guy got going because he
knows that's what he sees every day
right they're on the other side trying
to decide is this sustainable or is this
a moment in time keep going yeah and I
mean one thing that we're not doing
right now we're doing three to four
pieces of content but we're using that
same content on different platforms and
that's gotten us to where we are so are
you changing the copy we are good so
you'll take the same vid yeah so like
that's a quick hack that can really help
a lot of people here it's the same video
but the copy is different because the
audience is different on Tick Tock than
it is on LinkedIn than it is on Twitter
so something to think about just copy
changes or just slight little edit
changes yeah can matter yeah we've been
doing a little bit for YouTube uh like
the things that people search on shorts
and what are you seeing
um
we're also Gathering we're talking to
Joe maybe making content exclusively for
YouTube look even I have a repurposing
model with context but like there is no
comparison when you can make for a
platform because when I'm saying hey
Tick Tock versus hey everyone there's a
noticeable difference it just you know
I'm running a ton of businesses so it's
hard for me so I get it and but it's
real but the copy for sure don't mail
that in because it doesn't take a lot of
time you know like there's certain
things that you can mail in AKA like you
just don't have a timer resource and
energy but the a copy that's mundane
like yes I know it's easier to control C
and control V but like thinking like
this person's on Instagram versus this
person's on Tick Tock matters
copy in the description and title if you
have it on the content yeah if you're in
the editing mode and you can change the
title like titles that right the
thumbnail and titles I mean I don't know
if you saw the viral video of Mr Beast
like he spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars
on the thumbnail now he's playing at the
single highest level but I understand
I'm spending millions of dollars on a
team that is doing the same thing in
theory yeah
it's it's actually scary
how much the title and the thumbnail
Works which is why if you have a piece
of content keep this in mind that you
really like you just feel good about it
and you posted and didn't go retitle it
change the preview screen change the
copy go again three months later six
weeks later four weeks later
well I feel like we have a product that
I mean how much is it
it's 45 so we have a one month bundle
because you take it daily it's a daily
thing to support your hormones so it's
55 for one month and then you can get
three months it drops it down to 45 a
month and there's no one year we don't
have a one here why
what I like about one year is people
forget to unsubscribe and like like
things that nature and like you know
like it's definitely worth debating you
have longer tail you know to re-get
somebody to to get somebody to re-up at
month four versus the amount of people
that forget or are passive or neutral or
apathetic to it for one year is a lot of
money
how big is your drop-off after three
months
average right now for our users is 4.8
months up there with us yeah I literally
think if you go to 12 months instead of
three months that that number would be
9.7 months and if you're ever going to
go
yeah they're gonna be scared shitless
about if you're gonna raise capital
just too expensive to re-engage
what are you doing with your lapsed
users I got something really good for
you
I got a real good one for you ready yes
I think that you should call
on speakerphone every single person
who's no longer subscribed and once was
for three months
I think you should videotape the
interaction of you saying thank you
not try to sell them to re-up but just
to build a relationship around the
content
and when you have successful conversions
you ask them if there will allow you to
put out the video of this successful
reconversion I think there's something
there there
well first of all the reason you should
do it is market research
I'm adding content creation and
reactivation of business
and I think you're small enough still
where you could just grind that yeah
yeah totally oh we are all about
Radley yeah so calling literally calling
and saying I just want you to I just we
just want to thank you for ever being on
our service and just hopefully it
brought you some value and hope it
sprung you into action theoretically
whether you know we're obviously aware
that you're no longer using us but I
hope it's sprung you into a better you
thank you the most in so I used to do
this quite a bit for Wine Library the
most fun part of the phone call is when
you're done just doing love and good and
there's this awkward three second pause
because they're waiting for you to give
them an offer to reactivate but you
don't
yeah
try it even if you don't record it which
is probably the biggest friction of
everything I just told you I think the
market research you'll get to why people
unsubscribed like by the 19th call if
they all said the berries were the
problem you're like oh [__] should we
even have berries like it like it's real
market research
[Music]